new at noon today nevada's road map 2
recovery plan reached a critical point
towards reopening
bars restaurants gyms and other
businesses here in southern nevada can
now move to half capacity 50
and that is up from 35 percent some good
news hector mejia live now with the
latest changes hi hector
hey there in this locally owned thai
restaurant right behind me primaris says
they are excited to welcome back a lot
more guests
and here's a little bit about them some
say they serve up the best
patsy eu noodles in town many businesses
across the state are updating their
dining rooms now that they can operate
at half capacity
that changed overnight at midnight
restrictions easing from
35 percent to 50 percent at casinos
restaurants
libraries gyms and stores and looking
ahead on may 1st the governor says the
restrictions will fall on local
governments to decide
as well as some statewide mandates this
is all good news for struggling
businesses many say they've been able to
get by
thanks to loyal take out orders
hard very hard yeah the sale is not that
good but it's be still
quite okay but it's not that easy for
you know
for the business love to see the
customer coming and enjoy the food
more more people
also starting today if an organizer
wants to host a large gathering or an
event with more than 250 people
they may now have up to 50 percent
capacity if they complete and submit a
safety plan certification form
this would apply to conferences
conventions and trade shows and in a
written statement
lvcva president and ceo steve hill said
they know there is pent up demand
for the return of in-person meetings and
conventions and they are looking forward
to it
reporting near sahara and torrey pines
hector mejia 8 news now